then you ask well how do you contend  with things wisely and i would say well  don't pollute your thoughts with deceit  you compromise your own wisdom  how are you going to make intelligent  not intelligent decisions wise decisions  that's why you shouldn't lies like  you're warping the mechanism that  orients you in the world do you really  want to do that  this is a brutal world man and i've seen  this in my clinical practice  people whose houses are built on  foundations of sand and the wind starts  to blow and the floods start to rise and  they are in such trouble  such trouble  if you're lucky  and something terrible comes your way  and you're  reasonably honest and your relationships  are in good order  maybe you won't end up in hell  you you need to be afraid of that it's  like don't lie we're all subject not  least to the judgment of our own  conscience try to escape from that